once again on December 6th 2017 the
company specializing in machine learning
artificial intelligence known as deep
mind founded in 2010 by the way acquired
by Google in 2014
took on the world's strongest chess
engine stock fish in a match this is
game 5 from that match if you have not
seen our video review of game 3 please
click on the info and the related links
in this video go ahead and check out
game 3 before you dive into game 5
once again alpha zero was white and once
again started with a we'll say human
positional chess style approach playing
d4 knotty 4 and after East 6th 9 F 3
were actually on pace to get the same
type of opening that we had in game 3 in
a queen's indian so far they're
repeating exactly the moves from that
game bishop to b7 chosen by stockfish is
different than the move Bishop a6 Queen
to c2 which again if you haven't seen
game 3 and the analysis go ahead and
click on the link and backup and do that
but we add Bishop e7 which is a more
traditional development by black in the
Queen's Indian hereby stockfish and
after Bishop g2 Bishop e7 Recker OVA
castles again we get the same type of
positional pawn sack not the exact line
in the game 3 analysis d5 was played
after black had extended the c5 pawn
creating a different type of positional
dynamic where when the sacrifice happens
on the D file the d7 pawn is indeed
backward really struggling to advance
when white voluntarily pushes the d5
pawn you're doing so to take advantage
of the immediate pin possibilities which
happened right here after alpha 0 played
the move Knight h4 you're pinning a pawn
on d5 to the bishop on b7 hoping to
regain your pawn and if black does
nothing to prevent that make a random
move as an example now White has
expanded in the center will immediately
support that space advantage with a move
like e4 and and black is frankly just
positionally much much worse so in this
line playing the moves c6 is really
critical it's what separates this type
of gambit from again the analysis of
game 3 where the pawn was on c5 and
can't move backwards and it's really
crucial for black to hold on to that d5
pawn preventing as I said white from
just regaining it and getting a huge
space of ana
but after each aches d5 Knight takes d5
Knight f5 Knight to c7 we are following
theory as has been played again many
times it's always interesting to me when
we see two engines play top Theory as
has been assessed that's the best
approach by the world's best human chess
players especially one like deep mind
that apparently has had no human
influence outside of as we've said
organic machine learning which means
it's played itself about a million and a
half times that's probably even under
exaggeration
and has come up with these approaches on
its own so that that's really
fascinating to know that this is exactly
what he believed he being alpha zero as
the best line even though he hasn't been
fed opening theory and speaking of
opening theory after E for Bishop f6 and
now the move Knight to d6 we have
officially left opening theory the the
only previous games in this liner some
other moves including nice e3 but the
main other move in this line is to move
rook to e1 most notably if you looked at
this position in a database played by
Grandmaster try GU Boff just a big name
who played it recently that game went
after D v e5 and white actually got a
lot of compensation by eliminating the
dark square bishop and then taking on g7
dragon buff went on to win that game
despite black having a material
advantage again based similarly on kind
of what we saw the game three white
having long term compensation on the
dark squares but alpha zero I'm not
interested in that apparently or believe
that stock fish might have an
improvement and decided to immediately
put this Pony on d6
a very direct approach and in some ways
you could argue humans didn't play this
way because it seems a little over
committal the very there are very good
chances this night will end up being
traded for somebody who's not this dark
squared bishop which is what happened in
the traiga buff line and that's gonna be
less than ideal for white or so we think
because you really want this night to be
traded off for the dark square bishop
because that makes your dark square
bishop so much more powerful as it tries
to anchor in on all of these positional
weaknesses that white is getting for the
sacrifice d5 fine but by putting the
knight on d6 sort of you know with
without a lot of mystery that it forces
the line that we see here played by
stock fish and makes a lot of sense
black is gonna go out of his way to
to eliminate that night and keep his
dark square bishop so in in reviewing
this game myself i was looked at the
move Knight to d6 as a surprising sort
of deviation from the main approach
because I felt like it black my human
understanding if black could trade that
night as we said for anybody but the
dark square Bishop it certainly should
be good good for him but that's where
alpha zero tricked me in that in this
position he was never intending on
keeping the pawn advantage and taking
here which would be exactly what I said
a trade of a knight for the night
letting black keep the dark square
Bishop and all the things that I thought
would not be ideal rather alpha zero had
another another idea in mind which is
that he was willing to go down to pawns
not just one pawn but two so he takes f6
and after Queen takes f6 yes we have the
kind of compensation that white believes
can be super dangerous in this line you
have the dark square Bishop without
black having the counterpart you have
the D file but black is down black is up
two pawns here and and two pawns is a
lot of pawns I mean I think that's the
math so after Knight to c3 Knight to b7
I was looking at this position and and
sort of surprised and unlike my analysis
of game 3 where I
despite stockfish really getting
squeezed and and manhandled or I guess
deep mine handled in the last video
again check it out if you missed it I
never really criticized stockfish as to
having a better approach or or something
that was different I was you know alpha
zero just really seemed to outplay him
from start to finish but in this game
I'm gonna do a little differently here
after 94 and Queen to g6 and h4 yes
white is launching what seems to be the
potential of a pawn storm and yes white
has the dark square bishop the black
does not but being down to pawns and
being in a structure where it seems that
the only thing that makes sense is to
try to use your two pawn and manage and
expand them very quickly the positional
disaster that happened for black in game
3 again in a gambit in the Queen's
Indian was because the D pawn was never
able to move and white gets the grip
that is so devastating on the D filos
compensation and that ends up being
where we had here and so my main
question as you and as anybody who
analyzes this with stockfish at least
the mortal engine that I have without a
million jet engine CPUs tells me why
isn't black playing the move deep
I don't know why stockfish doesn't play
d5 to me it's the most principled thing
to do the best analysis I could come up
with was that white was still gonna
launch the attack with h5 then g4 and
now we're treating the knight even to a
move like g3 others maybe also some
other kind of weird sassiness there with
moves like Knight to g5 I tried to make
some sort of crazy pawns piece acts like
h6 work to try to undermine the f6
square but I don't see why black isn't
threatening to take the knight so I
looked at this position as yes a still a
decent amount of compensation for white
you have the dark squared bishop that
black doesn't and h6 is still coming but
as my stock vision here says as you can
see the evaluation bar and to me I look
at this as just a principle thing that
black needs to do you have to try to
expand and not let white get the grip so
so I am obviously taking my life in my
own hands as far as the commenters here
on twitch and YouTube and everyone's
gonna let me have it
Who am I to criticize stockfish but from
a principled perspective to mean d5 has
to be tried okay but after h4 stockfish
doesn't agree with me he plays h6 here
comes h5 with tempo note that now moves
like Queen a5 don't make nearly as much
sense anyway White's gonna continue to
launch the attack and you haven't pushed
the deep one so the Queen came back to
h7 but here's where the gloves start to
come off and if you haven't grabbed the
popcorn yet you still have a chance to
pause your video and see what went down
Queen new g4 awesomeness the immediate
threat is 9 ft 6 check winning on the
spot the immediate response that came to
my mind is uh why not f5
well there's actually several crazy
lines I want to show you one line that I
analyzed personally because hey I'm
doing the work here I can show you some
fun after Queen d1 takes e4 I was
looking at a line like this that almost
leads to some sort of strange smothered
mate and as crazy as this line is the
little pickle tickle here that the Queen
plays with the King to work her way into
g6 actually leads to just some really
really weird positions where I wonder if
White's compensation is okay black seems
to really like stock fish here but the
very least white would have a perpetual
here
I know alpha zero wants more than a draw
but to me this position again highlights
all the potential problems with this
type of session I thought it was a
really interesting thing and I
simply ran at a time to keep trying to
justify my crazy sack but the best move
after f5 is just the move Queen to h4
this move in in similar fashion
highlights that the e4 Knight is not
take a bowl because after takes takes
and Queen to g6 now it's a little more
straightforward with the bishop coming
into g6 and the threats are are numerous
and plentiful if that's a word
entry points on East 7n tree points on
EI t' again we have a position where
have we ever seen stock fish get his
Queen on such bad squares and
back-to-back games right I again
referring to game three so that would
have been a fascinating line stock fish
doesn't play it and plays the move King
h8 seems to be the simplest way to deal
with these problems of Knight f6 and
officially f5 has to be a threat now
right and here's where where a Lazaro
really just played a brilliant move no
other way to describe it so I won't
Bishop to g5 so much fun what's the
threat well ok after Bishop g5 let's
make a random move like d5 the move that
would positionally make sense and I've
been sort of saying black should have
tried for earlier here comes Knight f6
and you see the problem the knight is of
course poisoned due to Bishop takes f6
would be mate and if the Queen moves on
c2 there were several lines here but the
prettiest one I pick to show you is the
move Bishop e4 x clam d takes e4 and
Queen f5 exclaim a again boom
town on h7 and there's nothing black can
do to avoid the mate so that would have
been again a really fun way for this to
end stock fish is calculating well he is
still the world's strongest chess engine
as of all the dates previous to December
6 2017 but if so he plays f5 which is
better to stop might have 6 but after
Queen a for the f5 pawn is pinned and we
still have not solved our Queen side
development issues so here Knight to c5
was played I'm gonna again because I
said that I thought stock fish should
have played it earlier I wanted to know
all the other times where it was
possible again d5 was still a move that
could have been considered but now
several lines up moving the knight to
other squares as possible too but I
thought that white would actually still
have enough to be winning on Knight f6
takes f6 win the black queen and then
even enter into c7 I'm not exactly sure
if white is just crushing here but I
look at lack of development by the
knight here the rook is coming to the
e-file seems
why should still have enough because
normally the way you evaluate on balance
material positions it's not just the
math but whose King is weak or who has
the initiative and and here it feels
like white probably would have had
enough so that would that was my line
there okay so after Queen of four at
night to c5 was played and Bishop to e7
comes in the gloves are coming off
because the black pieces can't get in
the game and time to make up for what is
clearly an out of play Queen so as we
make the next few sort of obvious moves
here Knight to d3 Queen to d6 we see
alpha zero willing to sacrifice even
more material D take c4 was played
instead of D takes c4 if black tries to
play safe moves to get out of it there's
no way that's happening at this point
this commonly repeated tactical theme of
the night coming into f6 is is still on
the table so black does take on e4
pretty much the best chance after Bishop
b4 Brooke f5 is the only move to save
the queen
I guess Queen g8 I take the rook first
and and then I'll bring the bishop to g6
and and and when the Queen are made
later so I have two rook F 5 we get
Bishop h4 note that g4 is probably I
think winning for white as well but
black alpha 0 really being patient here
one of the biggest advantages being all
to show you the issue with g4 is that
black can save the day with rook d5 and
White's win is not so clear because you
take my queen I'll take your queen so
you might be thinking well what does
Bishop h4 do that that it's different
now on g4 the main thing is that this
rook cannot move anywhere due to the
fact that the bishop is no longer on e7
so moves like rook d5 are opening up to
chant to ideas where the Queen will
eventually come in to f8 very quickly
you can take d5 and then the Queen comes
in to f8 because as we said the bishop
on e7 is no longer in the way so after
g4 was played in the game that's
actually what happened okay Bishop takes
here here comes the pieces into the
eighth-ranked and now bishop g3 was
played so this was the last critical
moment where I really didn't understand
my initial human perspective why did
stockfish place 5 which after Queen to
d5 taking advantage of the pin went into
an endgame where white was up the
exchange and some good old-school
technique was going to win the game
first player what is white actually
threatening here why does black have to
panic what to move like c5 what did
these two juggernaut see deeper that we
don't so I analyzed it out instead of
instead of c5 let's play a move like a
five makes sense that eventually I might
try to get a position where my rook
could get into the game right sacrifice
the knight rather than the rook
so after moves like King to g2 another
move is played to try to free the
position what I realize is the biggest
threat the biggest thing that's gonna
keep black tied down is the move Bishop
to e5 as soon as this move is played
it's only a matter of time before all
whites trying to do is put black in
zoogs one yet again why well the bishop
on e5 freezes the Queen where she stands
any move by the Queen that isn't a check
is gonna allow Queen takes h6 and mate
so for example the Queen moves we get
takes in mate so that little tactical
theme over here on the Kings side was
really key and I said any move beside a
check so what happens on check well the
King moves and now your best move might
be to just bring the Queen back and
prevent the mate again so instead of
that let's say black continues to try to
free up space made some tation moves
with the King and we realized that it's
only a matter of time before black just
completely runs out of moves
nothing like a high levels looks wang of
this manner right where the brook moves
okay the night falls if the knight moves
okay the rook falls if the Queen moves
likely mate falls and we see that as the
as the longer stockfish gets to think
you only see that evaluation bar
shooting up further for white and just
really I thought that was a fun and
fascinating line to show the
difficulties and the long-term
compensation the white has here again
alpha zero was sacrificing pieces like
humans would write long-term
compensation where black can't get any
get anything go anywhere get outright
it's over stop fish played c5 and we get
to this endgame I don't want to paint a
picture that the game was just over here
alpha zero did put on some really good
technique to win the rest of this game
so I do want to show you a few more
moves if that's okay with you
Who am I kidding you're gonna stick
around or you're not either way so after
Knight f6 I found it interesting that
again like a good human chess player
alpha zero recognizes that there's
enough material advantage no reason to
go pawn grabbing and let there be any
kind of weird counter play right let's
just simplify into the endgame and get
this thing done old-school style
g4 Falls for a7 and speaking of getting
this thing done
human old-school thai-style after Bishop
e6 Bishop e5 and 97 one of the things I
found to be so fascinating over the next
few moves is that we're gonna find a
common theme here white emphasizes
proper coordination by the rook and the
bishop the constant threat of King
activity okay and keeping his opponent
from having an active King and proper
coordination as his top three things not
material not rushing forward so it's
good technique and good lessons for all
of us anyway so again keeping your
opponent off balance proper coordination
and the threat of King activity being
more important than any other smaller
amounts of material and and so despite
stockfish reaching kind of an ideal
blockade the bishop guards tonight the
night guards the pawns it's not so
simple how White's gonna break through
alpha0 makes the technique look pretty
easy here's the first example of it
totally willing to give up the h5 pawn
to make sure that he can emphasize
getting the bishop to c7 which forever
keeps the night tied down to b6
now we're gonna see that after some
proper coordination by the rook keeping
blacks King from getting active white is
eventually gonna make threats of
bringing his own King into the game
first he brings the rook to the e-file
nothing wrong with that especially
because it keeps this King from ever
having threats of entering into a more
active scenario again if this Knight
moves that's when that's when black will
have to worry about the shots coming
back to the pawn so black is kind of
stuck and that's that's what allows the
white King to eventually now make the
threat of activating itself up the board
after rook e3 we got some nice little
tickle here once again but patient
patient patient and we're not gonna sit
here and dive into all the little other
candidate moves for white there were
several but mainly just highlighting the
fact that the patient approach from
white really really nice to see and and
after the move rook e1 by the way the
immediate threat was Bishop takes c5
Knight takes followed by Brooke e5 which
is a good point because in this position
it's why black can't just continue to
sit tight you'd like to if as black but
white has finally got a position where
there is a threat something like this
would be would be a good win on the spot
so the fact that he can't just sit tight
means that he has to play the move h4
again trying to keep white from getting
the active
but that makes the h4 Pont vulnerable
now on the same color squares your
bishop and the the technique continues
we're gonna see again proper
coordination by the Brooke once again
not going for trades not going for crazy
lines don't play Brooke takes B 5 and
allow Knight to d4 play the move rook to
d5 and prevent black from ever reaching
the ideal squares with the knight right
this is just good old-fashioned family
fun after Bishop e6 46 again
coordination by the bishop is gonna help
to kind of keep this Knight at bay out
of these squares because after the rook
moves 94 wouldn't be good due to Bishop
c3 pinning it and of course d2 was
already guarded and so again all these
things were emphasized over the rushing
forward of anything and eventually
proper rook and Bishop coordination
combined with the threats of King
activity are gonna lead black to a
position where he really didn't have any
choice but to give up the b5 pawn which
wants this f5 pawn sorry the F pawn gets
in the in the in the job here which is
constantly threatening things like f5
where everything would be undermined
black had to give up the b5 pawn and
again so I guess I'm gonna go for
several more moves if stockfish played
it on will play it on but it really now
at this point I think officially was an
easier matter of technique just really
doing everything he can to avoid black
from ever getting threats and now that
the King side pawns have been eliminated
white begins the journey the greatest
adventure to come over to the Queen side
and when the C pawn Falls we really will
call it a day and say that once again
alpha0 putting on a show playing for
long term forms of compensation giving
us things to evaluate that make you
think could I just go play stockfish and
beat it right now
even though that's really not true but
please stay tuned leave a comment let us
know how you're enjoying this do you
find instructive value in these computer
on computer battles doing my best to
bring it please let us know in the
comments please subscribe and follow our
channels right here right now don't go
anywhere else and stay tuned to this
series as we bring you the next game and
what was our sort of chosen top 5 alpha
zeroes battle